[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar fluorescence molecular imaging
in head and neck cancer patients
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by andor to learn more visit
andor.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
flores bosco md phd postdoctoral
researcher head and neck surgical
oncology university medical center
groningen the netherlands
dr vasquel you may now begin your
presentation
thanks marie for a kind introduction
again my name is flores and
it's an honor to present the work we
we do in cloninger the netherlands the
most northern
city in the netherlands
uh
of course this is not only my work but
of the whole optical imaging group you
will see some
some of those people at the end of my
presentation in the acknowledgments
but i have the honor to uh to present
some of the work we we do
so uh please feel free to to ask some
questions also during the presentation
if i
get a
pop up in my screen i will try to
to answer them immediately and otherwise
we discuss it at the end of the
presentation
i have no conflict conflict of interest
so
don't worry about that and i want to
start with the movie
and
i'm gonna talk you through
so here you see a boost under the water
and this is how we surgeons
usually see the surgical cavity during a
cancer surgery so it all looks the same
and
no idea where the cancer is
and then
it would be a lot easier when
the cancer lights up like this
[Music]
this fish is doing as well so this is
also really a nice example of how we uh
we try to improve cancer surgery by
lighting up the the target tissue uh
which
enables us to delineate and and excise
radically
the the tumor
here again
um you can see it in slow motion but i
think you all
got it now
and i hope i'm still muted yes so
fluorescence guided surgery it's uh um
almost an
era already uh uh old and it was first
used in in the uh
[Music]
in the eye
with an uh sodium fluorescen
and in
2011 the first study was published about
clinical fluorescence guided surgery by
our group professor van damme
which
investigates the
ovarian cancer metastasis in the in the
abdominal cavity
and and by then the fluorescence has
interesting fluorescence surgery has
increased tremendously and
i will i will talk about that later as
well
so what can we do with optical imaging
and in my uh
specific field reference guided imaging
so we can
obtain margin control for cancer surgery
during surgery and after surgery we can
detect two religions of which we didn't
know they they were present or we didn't
know the exact location of the the two
press uh
tumor lesion
we could visualize the drugs when we
label them with fluorescence that's uh
um
of course of interest when you perform
surgery but also in clinical drug
development you can
label
your your drug of interest
and microdose to the patients and then
you can can investigate the actual
location
in the target tissue
uh we can improve the histopathological
diagnosis so the pathologist can use it
as well and during surgery we can
visualize some critical anatomical
structures like the
[Music]
large beans or or nerves etc
uh my my interest is mainly focused on
the intro operative margin control and
tumor detection
um
of which i will uh
for which i will continue my my talk
so it's always good to look back a bit
uh in 2007
our group started performing uh clinical
studies on fluorescence guided limiting
this was a study which i already
mentioned investigating ovarian cancer
this is when how it looks by then it was
custom made
by by our group in close collaboration
with the group of munich the technical
university of munich
with facilis
nissa frisos
as a group leader there
you see on the left our first clinical
camera
and you see a very large
device in the in the or which is covered
with a sterile grape to to get
interoperative uh
images
of course we we did some modifications
some some companies started with
stardust and skillset skill up
one of them is search vision which is
now
taken over by brecco
here you see the the camera which we use
a lot it's the search vision explorer
air it all looks a bit bit nicer than
uh 2007
and in fact it does work also a bit
better
we got
two of them in in at our uh place
and a couple of years ago we developed
uh together with search fish in the the
um
the vault which is a
kind of black box and you can couple it
to the to the camera head and then it
[Music]
generates a more standardized uh
imaging
field with no
uh
um
environmental light or or different
angles
or
different distances from tumor to to
camera head and i will talk about that
later why we think that's important
and once the tissue is excised we mostly
use the pro from the lycor
which is
developed as a
small animal
imager with with some custom
made changes it's very nicely a device
um to perform
progressions imaging on the excise
tissue specimen
so most of the images you will see are
obtained by these these devices
so fluorescence guided surgery um
as mentioned the it's a rapid
progression of the field and
by 2011 we published the first uh
inhuman study and by then it it's gone
like a completely massive growth
and i updated this slide last week and
we we now see
more than 350 clinical studies
investigating fluorescence guided
surgery with a lot of phase 3 studies
going on now um
so so this this shows that there's a lot
of interest in this field and there's a
clearly a
need for for better detection methods
during cancer surgery
but also during other types of surgery
or clinical
practice
so why why should we use those uh
techniques in cancer surgery now we know
and and we know it already for a long
time that we see unchanged high
prevalence of two and positive margins
many cell tumor types uh um to be honest
and we
on the on the graph on the right you can
see that uh
[Music]
the the past 20 years
um the the human positive margin rates
are are not
changed that much and and definitely not
increase
um or improved i have to say uh
dramatically where you might expect it
because we we have so much new
technologies and scans and cts and mris
but all those those uh two impressive
margins uh rates in in these these solid
cancer types um
don't change that much and in fact they
the the line is completely flat uh
in my opinion
and i'm mostly interested in the oral
cavity
i'm a
resident head and neck surgery so we
performed surgery on on the oral cavity
the tongue the mandible the floor of the
mouth
cheek etc
and we know that
the surgical
treatment in the head of neck cancer
the surgical margin is one of the most
important prognosticators for for
survival
and we know that unfortunately we face a
very high amount of inadequate margins
where the goal was to obtain a
free margin of at least five millimeters
around the tumor we see that
around twenty thirty percent we face
positive margin so
we we cut out the tissue without the
margin or with one millimeter or less
margin and we see a very high amount of
close margins with this one or one to
five millimeter healthy tissue around
the around the tumor lesion
and if we face an inadequate martin
which is correlated to an
worst prognosis it is indicated
that an adjuvant treatment consists of
chemo radiation which causes a lot of
severe side effects for the patients it
comes with increased local recurrence
rates and it comes with with increased
disease specific death rates
so it's uh it's our task to uh to reduce
those uh inaudible margin numbers
so here again what are those margins for
the for the non-clinical
attendees you see the cancer lesion in
in purple
and
the goal is to obtain at least
five millimeters of thermal free tumor
free surgical margin which is uh showed
on the left and the two positive margins
is when you cut through the tumor as the
image on the right shows but also when
you have less than one millimeter
healthy tissue around the
around the tumor adhesion
and that is that we believe that when
you get that close to the tumor margin
there are always
very small micro metastases around those
uh tumor lesions that we can see
and which might affect the local
recurrence rates so if we face a human
positive margin a juventus therapy is
necessary as mentioned in the previous
slide
so why then optical imaging in cancer
surgery
because of the current interoperative
guidance isn't
sufficient we use pre-operative imaging
we use physical and tactile information
during surgery we use fresh frozen
sexturing during surgery which is
obtaining a biopsy and then immediately
processed which is immediately processed
by the pathology department
however these companies vary these
techniques come with
problems for for guidance
during the surgery
the pre-operative imaging like the ct
and mri scan are not not real time and
we know especially in head and neck
cancer that those cancer diseases can
grow very fast so uh imagine that that
you perform an mri scan like one or two
weeks prior to surgery the situation
might have changed
and facing this is like
is is different
position at the at the operation table
so uh the correlation between the
appropriate imaging and the real-time
situation isn't that good
then during surgery the surgery the
surgeon uses most of um
the information he gets from visual and
technical information and we know and we
all can know and you can know that
that's a really low resolution of the
human eye it comes with a low positive
projected value and low
negative predictive value then you can
think okay we obtained during surgery
some some
biopsies which are immediately analyzed
by the pathology department the problem
is again
how to choose which areas you want to
investigate using those biopsies
and that comes with a high sampling bias
because you you you make a selection
again based on your your your visual
tactile information
and we know that these these rapid
process biopsies are
low of quality
so how can fluorescence then
then assist
will we think it can
assist the clinician prior to surgery so
it can enhance the the early diagnosis
um
which which might lead to a less
extensive surgery when you when the
tumor is still small and you already
visualize it with fluorescence
you can go for less
dramatic treatment
you can squeeze for satellite lesions
because we know in head and neck
uh area there's a high chance of a
second tumor lesion
and during surgery it can assist us in
delineation of the tumor it can help us
in margin assessment and again if we can
screen a satellite lesions so
from no information um
we think we should light up the tumor
which gives us
information prior to the incision during
the surgery and after the surgery in the
surgical cavity as you can see on the
the right uh right bottom image if
there's a
fluorescent spot left that might
be tumor
which is left and and during surgery
during the initial surgery it's often
way more easy to
do a immediate re-existing than a couple
of days after
so a lot of
strategies
for fluorescence guided imaging are
present you can either use the
non-targeted
imaging for example using icg which is a
lot of which is not done in the liver
surgery for example you can use
antibodies peptides
smart available
ph activatables
and our colleagues hansen and diem have
written a very nice review paper about
it
on the different compounds used in
fluorescent imaging
and
this presentation is
focused on two of those uh
strategies the antibodies and the uh the
pa is activatable and first i would like
to start with the antibody uh strategy
in this study we have used the tuxmap
800cw
which is a monoclonal antibody targeting
egfr
labeled with the fluorescent compound
iodi 800cv
cw
[Music]
so we call it the icon trial
why why do we use this detection up
targeting egfr because we know that over
90 percent of the oral squamous cell
carcinomas uh express
do overexpress the egfr
we cut the study in two phases in the
phase one and the phase two
the phase one is published
around two years ago now which in which
we investigated 15 patients
and it was mainly focused on finding the
right dose and the dosing schedule
and last december the phase two
have been completed we included 68
patients with this in
in our field uh
the largest clinical study um
investigating fluorescence guided
surgery in hand and neck patients and
the goal was to uh provide a positive
predictive value um
unfortunately i have some
very pre-preliminary data on it because
we're currently
on full speed analyzing the data and we
expect to to publish our first results
anytime soon
and we
performed quantification of the
intrinsic fluorescence because we
believe that that only looking at
fluorescence might not
uh be the best strategy especially in
those finding studies
i will come back to that later so how
does the study uh
look we included five dose cohorts of
three patients each
first we we did immediately the warm
dose uh i would call it so the map label
to uh i die
in three different doses the 10 25 and
50 uh
mid grams
and the the
the last two cohorts it consisted of uh
patients who received the pre-dose of
unlabeled citrix map
75 milligrams
and then followed by a label detection
up though so 15 or 25
milligrams and that's
mainly
done to
[Music]
reduce the background fluorescence
so after two days the surgery was
performed we performed a
intraoperative imaging using a surfacing
camera we performed x-fifo imaging using
the pearl
and we've performed of course a
histopathological correlation between
the fluorescence results and the
hispathological
hne slides
and everywhere you can see an s it
stands for spectroscopy we also
performed the spectroscopy
to obtain intrinsic fluorescence and why
is that what we believe that is
important
the intrinsic fluorescence is is in our
group
defined as correcting for the optical
properties of the tissue itself so which
is mainly the scattering and the
absorption and here you can see on the
left
uh what's happening to a fluorophore
when it's um
in the body and it's
it uh it absorbs it and and and emits
the the led
um
from the camera it's it scatters all
along it's absorbed so so only looking
at the fluorescence is in our opinion
not enough and on the the image on the
right you can see what what happens to
the
fluorescence
when you change the the optical
properties when you when you increase
the absorption or you increase the
scattering you can get completely
different
images of the fluorescence so especially
for those finding we we believe that
microscopy is an important parameter to
to investigate
so how does it look this is a uh
in vivo image of the fluorescence you uh
you can see here in
an image obtained with an endoscopic
fluorescence imaging system with this
custom built by us and together with
munich again
uh and here you can see uh uh
the floor of the mouth
and with it shows a large tumor
and you see clear fluorescence at the
tumor and no fluorescence at the health
the contralateral side
this is the open air system so when the
tumor is accessible using the larger
camera head we prefer to use the the
open camera because the resolution is
way better
and you can see here a buckle
another vocal this is a ton carcinoma a
lateral tongue carcinoma
and at the small yellow arrows you can
see in a second lesion which is a bit
more interior on the tongue
which wasn't
the surgeon wasn't aware of the second
lesion prior to fluorescence imaging so
here you see immediately the strength of
using fluorescence during surgery
and both lesions were excised during
surgery and turned out to be tumor
indeed
so this is how it looks during surgery
i'm now going to show an uh video
of
this this surgery as well
so here we see on the the small panel we
see the white light this is the the view
the surgeon has normally and on the the
large
view you see the the fluorescence you
see again in the lateral tone carcinoma
and the surgeon is getting it with an
electronic knife
to first to to set the existing
[Music]
borders and he's using the fluorescence
to to guide him where the
to what the extension the tumor is
present
present
so again not only looking at
fluorescence but also quantify it here
we see the
intrinsic fluorescent results of the
five different cohorts
from left to right the end label
of the the
only the label and on the right two
columns we see the the label followed by
the labels it takes them up
and we see a clear increase
in the fluorescence
when increasing the dose but we also see
a clear increase in the background
fluorescence when increasing the dose
without a free dose
i think
when you look at the uh
at the the tumor the background
fluorescence here
uh you see uh the the the three dose
groups um
um the background relations really
remains uh really low uh compared to the
to the tumor fluorescence so your your
too much background ratio
is way more solid
this is only the numbers and again when
we we take a look at the fluorescent
visualization you see here the real
strength of the pre-dosing um way less
background fluorescence and the the
tumor is way better delineated using the
fluorescence when you see those two
examples of the predose cohorts on the
right bottom
so based on these results we already
[Music]
wanted to choose the
one of the two uh
brito scores uh those for our phase two
study and when we look at the the x fifo
uh specimens again
on the the right hand side of this uh
this slide we see um a very
low background fluorescence
in the pre-dodge groups on the right
with increasing tumor fluorescence
and and
because there was no clear difference
between the uh 75 plus 15 or 75 plus 25
we decided to go for the 75 plus 15 uh
cohort
for our phase 2 study
by thereby limiting the the chance of
side effects and um the exposure of the
drug and on the left hand side you again
see here a very nice correlation between
the tumor
and the fluorescence and it correlates
to on the acne slide and the the eg
virus light as well
so it's nice that it works that we can
light up tumors
but does it really work in uh in the
clinic we usually we see a
freshly excised surgical specimen of a
floor of mouth tumor and when you go on
the left bottom panel you see a very
clear flattened spot on the ventral
resection side which correlates to two
and positive margin as you can see uh
on the atme slide
so here
if the surgeon sees during the surgery
he can immediately act by
if of course feasible and safe for the
patient to obtain a little bit more
margin
in the surgical cavity
so the results of this study we included
15 patients we detected four positive
margins which were in fact all four
positive margins in this study
we saw one false positive
which correlated to uh summon nebular
gland we know that the the glenn tissue
expresses also a bit of egfr
but we believe that's not a very big
problem because in general uh a surgeon
can discriminate tumor from
from these glands and we saw no
serious tracy related safety issues
so the phase 2
recently
finished
we are a bit
searching for the optimal uh tbr we used
intraoperative guidance
on the
tbr of higher than two
which is based uh on the
study of tumors published in terenosek
in 2018.
she
recommended at least a tbr of 1.5 we
believe that maybe a tbr higher than two
might might work better but we are
analyzing it
at least we identified all tumor
positive margins again 14 out of 14 and
we identified 11 out of 20 closed
margins
we again saw a bit of a false positive
margins
mainly based uh recall by glance
we saw one false positive
in an uh a previously transplanted skin
flap which turned out to be the the
large artery
feeding the the transplant
and we saw two lasers
which we
can't really uh uh explain it might be
that that were tissue optical properties
or some scattering or reflection um we
don't know
so these numbers and are
are again very preliminary but
we can say i believe that we could
potentially uh improve the surgery in
the uh 30 percent of the the patients
only based on on these tumor detection
using fluorescence guided surgery so
i think that there is a huge amount of
patients with my benefit from person's
guide surgery
so then i would like to continue with
another strategy
we now focus on the monoclonal antibody
and and
[Music]
by for using that you need to
know that it's uh the the tumor target
uh which you are investigating uh and it
needs to express egfr
and
and
it would help if the the normal tissue
doesn't express egfr
but what if if the the normal tissue
does express your target
or that no imaging compound is available
for your target
you don't know what what tumor you're
facing so you don't also don't do not
know
what what expression profiles these
lesions do have
or that the tumor expresses the target
really
heterogeneously
or that you don't know where the
tumultion is
originating from
so then you can use another strategy
a compound called the om100 which was
developed by the the group of
jimin gao and baron zimmer at the ut
southwestern it targets basically the ph
of the tumor and we know that tumors are
a bit more acidic compared to healthy
tissues because
the warbuck effect which is in fact
[Music]
the the the thing that tumors produce
produce a lactic acid despite the
presence of um
of uh
o2
um and they they
developed a compound which is uh um
which you can see on the right
which is in an off state when the the ph
is higher than the threshold and which
is in on state when the ph is below the
threshold
how does it work
it consists
of my cells which are nicely aligned in
the off state and where the fluorescence
compound is is located in the center and
by quenching there's no fluorescence
when the the micelles fall apart
the they are getting unquenched and the
fluorescence is uh is turned on
here you can see it on in a microscopic
image
on the left you can see the mic cells
in a in a
[Music]
nicely uh
[Music]
which are
the fluorescence compound is enclosed by
the myself because um the ph is higher
than the threshold so they're squenching
no fluorescence is visible
when the ph is below the threshold the
micelles fall apart and um
and the fluorescence is activated
they developed a
platform that they can tune the um
the threshold from all ph
that you want
um
and we are
the ones that that first uh uh
firstly uh tested this uh this compound
uh in clinic
we because it's uh tumor agnostic we
believe
we we tested the the compound in a lot
of
different cancer types of course had a
neck cancer but also geo cancer breast
cancer and colorectal cancer
we again divided the study in two parts
part one is the dose finding again five
times three patients
and the part two was those verification
of the optimal dose decided in the
first part
so if we look at those selection we uh
we can see that they're uh by increasing
the dose
higher to the background ratio
were refined performed
and um
because of uh
no clear difference um uh between the
1.2 and 0.8 we decided to uh go for the
1.2
and um
[Music]
this this dose we tested uh in in again
another 5-15 patients
and here on the left you can see
that the uh
the tumor was in in all patients more
fluorescence compared to the adjacent
moon tumor tissue
we can see that there is a solid tbr of
4.5 which is considered to be very high
in our field and we have a very uh
solid area under the curve
in the rc curve by of
0.79
19.97 excuse me
so we're very uh happy with these
results
so then the uh
the the images
let me uh talk you through this this
image on the left you see um tissue
specimens of the representing
[Music]
cancer types and you see head and neck
cancer breast cancers geocancer and
colorectal cancer
you see a very
[Music]
charge delineated fluorescent lesion at
the tumor location
which is not
not visible in the healthy tissue
which is a column on the right of the
the middle column actually and we see
again um and excuse me the graphs have
become a little bit small that you can
look it up uh in in the paper uh which
uh i have to reference on my last slide
that in in all tumor types um the tumor
was more fluorescent than the decent
non-tumor tissue
so
again how does it look in the patient we
we see here some carcinoma
and we will image both uh both sides
so here you see uh the fluorescent uh
lesion of a very large tongue carcinoma
the non-fluorescent part in the center
was completely necrotic so no non-viable
tumor was was present there
and here you see the contralateral side
which is clearly uh way uh way less
fluorescent than the healthy side
and then the tumor
side again a tumor lesion
of course we validate it
microscopically you can see a sharp
delineation between the two more and the
endostroma
um
where you can see that the tumor
is really fluorescent um
showed in the green here and the the
healthy
stroma
doesn't show any fluorescence
so now it's getting interesting this is
some
two patients actually in where we
detected
accumulations that we didn't expect
prior to the surgery on the the top
image shows say the peritoneal cavity
which is in fact the abdominal cavity
you look from the inside to the outside
and you see there at the at the
arrowhead
a small lesion which uh turned out to be
a um
metastasis of colorectal cancer
and in the
penalty you see uh surgical cavity after
directly after uh
oral cancer surgery you you look at the
lateral tone again and you see a very
clear fluorescent spot which turned out
to be a satellite
metastasis as well
how does it look
once the specimen is excised you can see
here a breast cancer specimen after a
lumpectomy so you excise a part of the
breast
and you see again
at the specimen a clear fluorescent spot
which corresponds to a tumor positive
margin which you can see on the right
hand side of this image
here you can see the uh
the tissue slices after the
pathology department has sliced it we
call bread or slices because it's yeah
you can visualize it as a bread which is
sliced
um and there you have all
all these slices of around four to five
millimeter uh which are further
processed um towards hme sections but
here we can see on the in those uh
slides that that we
detect some uh some fluorescence
um which turned out to be all
metastases um uh which were detected by
pre-operative imaging which were
detected by the uh pathologist
which which wasn't um
enclosed for further histopathological
processing um if if we
didn't find it with the fluorescent
imaging so you can see here the clear
additional benefit of performing
fluorescence
imaging during the pathology
processing
so in this study
we had nine tumor positive resection
margins uh which we all detected uh in
this uh
this study
uh of course uh no test is perfect we
and we also saw some
negative resection margins
uh with fluorescence
so where do we stand after
these two studies um
first we can not only look at the the
primer primary tumor lesion but also uh
to the lymph nodes we uh we analyzed it
on the substrate
uh my colleagues uh funk and
and uh and david uh published recently a
study on the
person's guided surgery
performed on lymph nodes and actually it
works
you can look it up
by yourself
it's published in the joint of nuclear
medicine
we
we believe
that standardization is is key in our
field um and a nice paper to read
[Music]
on that is published by our colleague
hey mom also in the journal of nuclear
medicine and we know that
the
imaging results are are largely
influenced by
the most stupid things like the the
distance from camera to patient the
angles the light the the the
environmental light at the
[Music]
detector head the angle of the detector
so
we believe that standardization is key
to to bring this field uh further and
and in that regard we we should think uh
of of the
uh
the idea
if we should go for it for in vivo
imaging or that that for a lot of
indications actually for imaging where
the environment is it's much more
controllable
might might surface as well
we need
hardware
changes or improvements which would
generate
information on the depth of the
fluorescence
and we believe that that only looking at
the fluorescent lesion alone
does not
gives us enough information because
fluorescence can can come from a couple
of millimeters below the surface which
checks the enough margin in in some
tumor types so a strategy for that is to
obtain directly a guided fresh frozen
sectioning guided by the progressions
and which then can be analyzed using 3d
progressive imaging
and in the future in the
not too far distant uh
future i believe that that that upgrades
and are are
mandatory and they are coming on on
devices which generate the 3d
information on the fluorescent
compound
and again
we believe that x-fifo might be
in some cases preferred over mp4 imaging
because we we think that's a better
controlled imaging environment
then we can immediately combine the
expertises of the surgeon and the
pathologist
and still enable
real-time data acquisition
we published
a couple of
papers on that which are as shown here
and a nice read for you if you're
interested in this
this field is our recently published
perspective in the nbme
which you show here in on the purple
with the purple header
so the next step we believe is to go for
specimen driven mars in assessment which
still allows intraoctive margin control
which allows combined expertise of the
pathologist and the surgeon
and
we call it the intraoctive
surgery so this is where we believe that
the field is going
for for our indication head and neck
martian assessment
in the coming
coming years
and as i started my presentation i also
would like to to finish it
of course this is not only my work it's
a
huge team
behind it we've got a
couple of pc students
i believe now around the 15
to 20 pg
candidates
and those four uh guys
were
a great help in performing these studies
we've got three principal investigators
uh which are uh very very uh helpful and
and uh the study uh performing a study
uh it's key that that your um
non-non-principle investigator
surgeons
are are more than willing to participate
because it costs time it costs extra
work
in the
in the in the start of the years
and of course all the the existing
departments like the hospital pharmacy
pathology
et cetera
so big thanks to them as well
and then i come to to the end of the
presentation if you are interested in
this
this field i would recommend
those four uh reads um that if you go on
pubmed and you you you search on my name
or or one of the the pis you you find a
lot of interesting papers as well
um
so i think um i give back the word to
mourinho and
we can go for a q a session
thank you dr vasco for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
is imaging limited to surface layers
is it possible to work with deeper
tissues and if so to what depth
yeah that's a really interesting
question thanks for that
uh yes it is the the
techniques we are using uh imaging is is
possible
a couple of millimeters into the tissue
um
it's reported up to six millimeters i
think that's a bit optimistic i would
say two to three millimeters
max four
but there are um upcoming new techniques
um
um i don't know if you're familiar with
it but the the mso system developed by
the group of uh facets integritos
which is using
sound
ultrasound
weight length
to generate a
deeper tissue penetration so the laser
is
is emitting
wavelength and it's the
the vibrations are detected by
ultrasound and it's reported that you
can can image
in up to one one centimeter so that's
really interesting
um
so if you're interested in the in that
um
look look for some papers of facilities
group
great thank you
next question
would using labels with higher
wavelengths in the near infrared reduce
scattering and improve the signal and or
detection
uh yes that's a good question as well uh
in theory yes we know that the higher
wavelength and this is called the near 2
area which starts from around
1000 nanometer
um
face a lot less
scattering
so currently there are not that many
devices which which are able to detect
those those
far near wavelengths
we actually
are performing a study now using uh
near two
of which results will be the first
result will be presented at the uh
european and molecular imaging meeting
um in greece in um in a month from now
so then i
hope to speak to you
more on this topic
awesome great
um and it looks like we have time uh for
just a couple more questions this next
question has multiple parts so if you
want me to repeat any of them
uh just let me know
uh says i wonder how did you select your
regions of interest when quantifying the
data both for tumors as well as for the
background to calculate tbrs
was it x vivo or in situ
what advice would you give to avoid bias
when selecting
rois and performing quantification
yeah that's a great question and i think
one of the most important
topics especially when when you're
you're analyzing
a uh
compound for the first time
so we did backwards planning uh so to
say so first we
asked the pathologist to delineate the
tumors on the hd section without knowing
any fluorescent results and then we
overlay those
those hd sections on the
tissue slices
of which we collected fluorescent
imaging
images so it was x vivo because i
believe that
for a tbr
calculation
a selection of the roi in vivo of which
you don't have any histology isn't that
reliable it's it's nice to to look but
to prove that that you have a solid tbr
and and that the fluorescence is only
taken up in the tumor and not in the
surrounding tissue you need to
have histology uh data and that's only
feasible
that's only
available uh x devo so we we first
asked the pathologist to deal in the hd
section and then we look back on our
fluorescence imaging
i hope that answers your question lukas
great thank you so much
and it looks like um we're have we have
time for one more question
what is the minimum size of tumorous
tissue that can be detected
that is a
great question that that i think it
depends on the resolution of your your
camera as well and and of course of the
um
quality of your your compound
in the first study where we which we use
the
satoshi mob
we detected a tumor lesion of around the
two millimeters uh and in the the second
uh study i showed
um
we were even able to detect the 1.5
millimeter satellite lesion so
yeah around one two three millimeters
when using these
the current devices available
great
and we actually have time for one more
question um are you planning to validate
these techniques in other centers
yeah yeah absolutely i think now
phase two is
finished in our center which are
almost 70 patients that's a lot in our
field um the the study was was over for
i think three and a half years we had
some hiccups so you can imagine that
already
but but we we believe that that when if
you want to prove that it's a feasible
technique for
for not only academic centers but for
all uh surgeons you you need to prove
that it's
not only
working in my hands but
you should run a solid phase three
steady we are now in the
in the orient uh uh orientating uh phase
uh we have some some really nice
other head and neck centers in the
netherlands maybe also
other
centers in in europe to to go for a
phase three trial multicenter so i hope
that we can initiate that in the
upcoming period
excellent well thank you again dr vasco
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor andor for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you